speaking of wedding season what are some
of the top trends this year as couples
walk down the aisle here to tell us more
is lifestyle expert lisa jaroszak hi
lisa how are you
hi so good to see you thanks for having
me oh we can't wait to talk to you
because the show stopped let's we're
talking about wedding trends what's
going to be big this year and usually
the showstopper of any wedding is the
dress so let's talk dresses what styles
are we going to be seeing this summer
yeah i mean there's lots of things that
are new this year i would say the
biggest trend is doing two looks
right more of a traditional ceremony
dress and then switching into a more
short
sexy maybe a little bit more personality
dress for the dancing part of the night
and the other thing that's really big
right now is a bold sleeve right so the
really willowy sleeves or something
really big and poofy which i feel like
was popular in the 90s and 80s and is
coming back strong in a new chic way oh
that look is so romantic it's so
beautiful i love it let's talk a little
bit about some traditions that are being
reimagined usually the wedding party
will gather the night before a wedding
for a rehearsal dinner but
that tradition may soon be replaced can
you tell us more about that
yeah i mean i would say traditionally it
was that everybody had a rehearsal
dinner right and you'd invite your
immediate family and your wedding party
and they'd come to the dinner but with
so many people getting married and
traveling from different places whether
they moved or their family moved or some
people are coming from overseas i'm
seeing a big trend of doing more of like
a welcome party where everybody's
invited it's light bites and more of a
cocktail party versus a formal rehearsal
dinner
that's actually kind of nice that it
includes everyone on that and then
finally when we wrap up the festivities
we do that with a little wedding cake
but what can we expect to see when it
comes to treat trends this year
well that's my favorite part of the
night so
i mean definitely sweets tables are
really in right now i think that people
like the idea of variety they want to
bring in
different suites that maybe mean
something to them whether maybe they
really enjoy going to a certain
cake shop or for a specific suite some
people are trying to bring in gelato
carts or something that's more
interactive like a donut wall or all of
the above so ending the night on
something sweet and even like a candy
bar that people can take with them is a
lot of fun oh i love that idea gelato
carts donut walls let's do all of it
thank you so much for your time and
expertise lisa we appreciate it